tan
[音楽]
ああああああ
早速ですいませんけど皆さんちょっと目をつぶっていただけませんか
目をつぶって想像してみてください
あなたはある島国で幸せに暮らしていました
ところがある日外国の科学者がやってきて
アートの国はこれからだんだん海に飲み込まれて200年くらいすると消滅してしまう
かもしれないと表現しました
それは自然現象ではなくて人間のせいだと言うんです
その人間とはあなたの国を日立ではありません
どこか遠い国の人たちがやったことが原因だといいます
その外国の人たちは自分たちに原因があることを理解してましたが金銭的な補償する
つもりはないと言いました
住めなくなった人を少しは受け入れてもいいけど全員は無理だなと言いました
ひどくないですか
想像してみてください
もしもその消滅する国が
あなたの住む日本だったら
目を開けてください
今のは昔見た映画で評決のときという映画のですね
真似をしました
皆さんに沈みゆく島国住む人たちのことを想像してもらいたかったからです
重たい始まり数してません
申し遅れましたが僕は江守正多と言いまして
気候変動つまり地球温暖化の研究
特に将来予測の研究をかれこれ20年以上しているものです
気候変動でどれくらい深刻なことが起こるんですかというのをよく聞かれます
僕はその問いには科学だけでは答えられないと思っています
しかしまずは科学的にわかっていることをお話したいと思います
これは地球の気温変動のコンピューターシミュレーションです
青が本土が下がる色赤が上がる色を表しています
こんな風に地球の気候は年々不規則に変動しています
その結果たまたまある年に高気圧が居座れば猛暑が起きるし強い低気圧が来れば大雨
おきますそれは昔からたまに起きる自然現象です
しかし人間活動によって大気中に co2などの温室効果ガスが増えることで
ご覧のように
企業が平均的に上がっています
するとたまたま猛暑のパターンになった時に平均的な温暖化の分の気温上昇は上乗せさ
れるので記録的な猛暑になりやすくなる
大雨も温暖化で大気中の水蒸気が増えた分
雨量が上乗せされるので記録的な大雨になりやすくなる
これが
今起きていることです
ここから
私たちの世界は分岐していきます
上側は人間活動による co2の排出量が更に増え続けていく世界
下側 co2の排出量減少に転じさせてどんどん減らしていって実質ゼロまで減らして
いくことができた場合の世界です
どちらの世界でも平均企業はまだしばらく
上がり続けます
しかし co2の排出量を減らしていく下側の世界では気温の上昇が産業革命から2度
より10分低く止まります
これが2015年に世界を合意したあり協定が
目指している世界です
一方で co2の排出量は増え続ける
上側の世界では気温が上昇し続けます
したがってより記録的な猛暑も大雨ももっと起きるようになっていきます
そしてこの場合は
さらに大きな地球の異変が起きることが心配されているんです
このバケツを見てください
バケツにゆっくりと水を注いでいくと
あるところを超えたときに
こうやってひっくり返ります
つまり外側からゆっくりとした変化を与えているのにある臨界点を超えた瞬間に急激で
不可逆な元に戻せない変化が起きます
こういうのティッピング減少と言います
地球の気候にもこういうティッピングの性質を持った変化が起きる部分があると考え
られています
例えばグリーンランドの氷は今徐々に温暖化が進むことによって徐々に溶けていますが
気温がある臨界点を超えると不安定化して溶けるのが止まらなくなる
つまり気温がそれ以上上がらなくても
あとは勝手に溶け続ける状態に入ると考えられています
南極の氷の流出も同じようにティッピングを起こす恐れがあります
グリーンランドや南極のティッピングが起きると海面上昇が加速してしまいます
それからアマゾンの熱帯雨林は温暖化と森林伐採がある
臨界点を超えるとかれるのが止まらなくなる恐れがあります
しかもこれらのティッピングは次々に連鎖してしまう恐れも指摘されています
つまり最初のティッピングがスイッチを入れてしまうと後はドミノ倒しのように次々に
ティッピングは起きてしまうかもしれません
これらのティッピング始まる温度ティッピングポイントは正確にはわかっていません
しかし温暖化が進めば進むほどティッピングポイントを超えてしまう恐れが高まって
いくことは確かです
今生きている私たちの世代が
このティッピングをスイッチを入れてしまう恐れが十分にあります
そしてその影響は遠い将来の世代にまで及びます
最後に
最初に想像していただいたほかの国の人たち話をしたいと思います
自分たちは温室効果ガスを先進国の人たちに比べたら殆どだしてないのに
つまり温暖化の原因にほとんど責任がないにもかかわらず最もひどい目に遭う人たちが
います
それは海面上昇で国土が失われていく小さな島国住む人たちばかりではありません
干ばつが増えると本当に食べ物も週にもなくなってしまう
乾燥地域の貧しいのに
それから強い台風やハリケーンでそして海面上昇でさらに強化された高潮に襲われて
済むところを失う
沿岸地域の発展途上国の人たち
氷が減って環境が大きく変化して伝統的な文化を奪われ
移住を余儀なくされる北極圏の先住民族の人たち
そして同じ国の中でもより酷い目に遭うのは
より社会的に弱い立場の人たち例えば
貧しい人たち病気の人たち
差別を受けている人たちのです
こういった人々への被害は多くの難民を生み出すかもしれません
紛争の引き金は拡大要因になるかもしれません
それによって国際関係が不安定になれば私たちにも影響が及びます
さて
もしあなたが自分が直接受ける被害にしか興味がなかったとしたら
同時にもしあなたが十分にラッキーであれば
気候変動の深刻な影響はしばらくは他人ごとであり続けるかもしれません
だってあなたはエアコンの効いた部屋にいれば暑さな関係ないし
ニュースで遠くのどこかの号被害の映像を見て大変だなと思う
その程度かもしれません
しかしそうしている間にも世界のどこかでは深刻な熱波8号や高潮や干ばつや山火事で
命を落としたり生活の基盤を失う人たちが増え続けます
しかも彼らにはほとんどその原因に責任がないにもかかわらずです
そして無関心な私たちが無関心に温室効果ガスを排出し続けていれば
熱波も豪雨も高潮も干ばつの山火事もこれからもっともっと記録的になります
つまり
気候変動でどれくらい深刻なことが起こるかという問いの答えは
私たちがこういうことに思いを巡らすあ
想像力次第なんです
こう考えると気候変動全力で止めるのは難しそうな気がしてきます
皆が皆そのような想像力を持って気候変動深刻に受け止めてくれるようになるとは
なかなか思えないからです
しかし僕は希望があると思っています
もう一度すいません目をつぶってみてください
想像してください
あなたが住んでいる国では気候変動の被害を深刻に考える人が少なくて
気候変動の対策に真剣に取り組む人も少ないです
しかし一部の人達が
気候変動が発展途上国の人たちや将来世代の人たちに与える残酷な影響に自分たちも
加担してしまっていることに気がつき
政府や企業や自治体に働きかけを始めました
政府や企業や自治体の中にもそのことに気が付く人が増えてきました
やがて太陽光発電風力発電電気自動車などが安く作れるようになって co2を出さず
に社会を発展させることができるとだんだん多くの人が思うようになりました
そうなってみると co2を出さない社会をつくるのが自分たちにとっても世界にとっ
ても将来世代にとっても良いことなんだから
当然そうすることが喜んでそうすることがいつのまにか新しい常識になりました
想像してください
もしその希望のある国が
あなたの住む
日本だったら
目を開けてください
新しい常識を作る想像力は
私たち一人ひとりにあります
ありがとうございました